数車ちょっとアクセス z 分
皆さん youtube でまぁもありません今見ているこの画面が皆さんデビュー
youtube で youtube って動画を見る前に入った新聞で夢だし的な
ため寝るというものがあるんですありますどんな動画なのかっていうのは蛍一つの画像
としてさまでいるっていうのが動画を見る前に皆さんクリップ
いいと思うんですけどもそのサムネイルエロんなユーチューバーはもっとバカを見て
欲しくてみて欲しくてどのクルーズがイサベルを作るフォンに強く頭に措置も大事です
卒中と答えず自分アベニューわー
うけど一番大事なんだよねそうですよ内容も大事なんですけども
サムネでも同様見てもらうために大切な要素になってきますそれで今回は
サムネイル対決することで茹でる i 月
どっちがより優れたサムネイルを作るかご台を一つ出されるんでお題に添っと冷めると
作って対決
わーい
ですねなるべくなるべく見てもらえなねべてみてもらえた気になるような
みたいっなんだこの動画みたいなもう見たかすればサメの積んだ人が勝ちという
なるほどゲームでございますか小さいよいま僕の部屋着雨具の際食べるのであるほどの
皆さんにさんに発信させてもらってどっちが優れた
サムネイルあーだという
そうですしようと最初のお題はたパンと食べてみた
卵を食べてみたぶーまあ youtube で求められるのはいかにヴォルカ
イヤーいかに守るか以下に卵を食べてみたベスト3歳でルカって言うなよを戦い制限
時間10分ではあああっ
ブーブー的な方いかがだったでしょうか30
まあ感じ30パーまだじゃ私じゃね4つからいきますよ私の作ったサムネイルは50
です
どーん
甘いでらっハーフ甘い甘い甘い卵だけじゃちょっと伝わり剤で鶏本物にやと6本とも
甘いの後口僕の口はちょっとでかくしたんだねぇ
素晴らしいつまりはいじゃあこれいい勝負ますんでな印象ですかね根津はこちらです
入っはっはー
じゃあこれアナはをで際卑怯だわー
youtube で大雪のニュースを2つ含めますね一つだ女の人にフォトこの子はね
女の子れると見たくなっちゃうから
女の子ひょっとして手渡しでもらった球を含むのかなっていう妄想が膨らんでしまって
ついつい行ったほうが食べてみたらという動画を見てしまう奴はやっぱり君良型
大量にやっぱたぁー
南なんですがご飯するみたいになってますけどどうぞ宗谷僕はねさんの生徒もらったん
ですよね付シートかねこれはこれ載せようとしてますよお姉さんのお尻からタマゴって
き釣りはやめましょう
はいじゃあこれが言うでもこれは極めるなそれに性差が読めるんですからね
卵を食べてみたという動画があるとしたらどっちが覚めるの方が観たくなるかと言うん
だろうって
の肺結核でございました選びました
だめだ選んだのは
よっちですよ
ああああああああニャー
re too
かあっちったぁああヌードっきりしかティ
何のドッキリかはお任せしますさーああなるほどあの代目ではなく
さんネイルで勝負するかいそうですよねそう設計時間20分
そうだ
下たんだ
くっつけっ
入ってあっはい自分でも違うあっいや俺をすごいカメラ
こうやってるってやっぱりだうーんうっ今日はい終了
ブーバーよ僕の
のサムネイルドライブしてるぞこちらですはいはっはっは
あーちょっとあってはぜこれ当然ちゃうじゃんって
版ってコレまずほどさっきの地下でつくったからねまあ要するに青いらがちょっとずれ
て階段やし女の人に行って服全部はがれて本当にし命の危機を感じるドッキリっていう
これも大きい方稼げてるじゃんそっちはかなりそういう麻雀やったりして説くところ
する彼女6色ですよ本当に凍っ
みたいな言ったら女心結構くすぐりますね
スクーのメインチャンネルで上げてそうな歌詞にゃんこ皆さんな
早速審査なおに入りましょうよろしくお願いしまーす今回のタイトルは
ドッキリしてみたねなるほどデーのはいいい
バッハ
japan 難しいですよね俺は
んなるほどはから上海へましたでは結構
結果は
始め佐藤者
いやこれは取り僕は見たいかもなんかインピョやばいんだっ日なんか結局
youtube のシステムゾーン見れないからさ
その付けないんだけどね new tube こっちも間に youtube で見れ
ないようながいいを走ってる
あっはぁこれは負けたぁー
hyde 着でコンクール装具はまあ一体いつも必要ということですねはいなかった
ありがとうございますいい経験になりましたーーー
またいつかしろこれは直付しましょう系着付けましょう本当にいろんなやついえばもつ
いろんなを作れると思うんだよしかまたいって聖者商品や e 賞だったよありがとう
ございます
また津田タカ理由はまだ戦いましょうというのまた次の動画でお会いしましょうじゃあ
じゃないん
me
バッハ
いったことに気